welcome to this video I'm playing cruel
tov tov is the name without any name in
there he's played a three against this
is solely and yes this is in fact a line
there's even a book published about it i
think there was in two books published
about this which I found pretty
remarkable because of a three really um
okay he's playing the Grand Prix attack
but without the bishop move this is
actually quite interesting as it there
is the same thing with colors reversed
and what is the move there mmm a
three-hour a3 is not really helping him
but it's also not damaging much after he
60 probably played deform if he has some
idea with it oh well recovers recolors
reverse there is d5 I can show you this
later okay he's a plane before Wow yeah
cool yeah there is there are things that
you have absolutely never seen after 25
years of chess like this not sure what
it is is it good is it bad it's
interesting that's clear in d6 I member
i can't see cuz he's got five now hmm
yeah there is some point to it I wonder
ever should play I think I should do
that play up sticks I must I must break
up this bishop otherwise if he gets
enough time like 94 Bishop b2 and so on
he will dominate on the dark square so
I'm trying to open up the position his
setup has one disadvantage it's slow a
three before many pawn moves if he takes
Knight eggs i'm actually threatening 95
180
i knowi six is weak but it's a it's
dynamic cm okay what the heck mmm 97 on
this a bit too mm too lame I take on e5
I would like to take on fire but hmm
yeah this is a good move actually I
Bishop d7 ok let's do let's do this
attending night to deform maybe he's got
94 now mmm this could be annoying
hmm 94 intending 96
yeah this very it's very rare that you
that an ID on d6 is not a problem and
here it would have been a problem yeah
wow how to develop this oh wait here's
castled I can play f5 here yeah and I'll
do that I know I know it's not exactly
consistent with f6 opening up the long
diagonal and so on but it controls eform
and I think this over wills are or
disadvantages or let's say yeah it I
don't mind that this is a bit
inconsistent but 94 is prevented now
once and for all and okay the g7 bishop
is looking at the five porn not great
but White's bishop on c1 also will never
have a really good good life in this
game I hope that's always looking at the
f4 porn or it can get try a four or
whatever this is not really a problem
look b7 hmm it's maybe intending again
I'd be five again let's let's just let's
just keep it simple yes I thought 94
would cover it rg5 attacked e6 oh wow
really really really really okay take
that check Knight takes a thick only six
year
isn't the night trap 2797 check King f8
right it's not trapped because of this
should be two at the end Wow ok but I
can go to d5 actually see seven is
covered six check ok I'm I must play I'm
on one minute something
but I can take it you can take the night
this is stupid I can just take on b5 I
mean night Jake's King obsession yeah
then take on b5 at some simple and good
solution well maybe there is something
better I'm not not sure about it but 95
some desperado muth maybe yeah II 60
will open up the long diagonal but not
sure how terrible it really is try 94 36
if possible
hmm yeah not sure the creature aid is
not so terrible on me if the night has
some potential only six I know I'm upon
down but I think it could have been
worse I mean I'm not into the astok
about this position but I think I was
worse even c4 know this rook c3 but then
this Knight c3 time Barney oh come on
I'm let's go ahead
now this didn't really help it did not
help this this only improved White's
position may I'm really a bad game that
I'm playing in okay I'll take it Oh
check know is he's really struggling
check I really want to trade ropes this
wood he's my job considerably it'll
enter with the rook this Bishop is
almost wrapped rook a tubal chocolate
neck smooth we are very lucky game
resides he really fell apart with the
time getting low this was probably lost
that were more than one point yeah
that's a crazy opening with before I
mean not not at all sure what this is
it's maybe not so bad I mean I cannot
well just for starters I cannot take
here I mean this is just after Bishop a3
really really strong compensation I mean
something like that is probably
completely terrible so I must I must
essentially here well maybe you hmm
that's an interesting suggestion the
computer gives the smooth
35 not clear that this is so great yeah
ft 6 lb six yeah this is what I played
but this looks I don't know it looks
dangerous and here i don't i don't
really know well maybe I panicked here
with this Bishop 37 move from in our
panicked is wrong i mean just errored
Bishop d7 seems bad maybe it still 97 it
didn't feel right to me the problem
however with Bishop d7 as just this
movement I'm and I'm toast I think yeah
1.5 by the company not looking good
something like this or why does very
well developed in good pieces this idea
no yeah and this I don't know computer
hates it but I don't think it is so bad
actually it's a bit more passive or
something but yeah this is really a
problem but what's my defense that this
is the defense that the computer
suggests then castle and see how this
this looks pretty ok chat here yeah this
is something simply not working night f5
is a possibility this desperado my night
has no square so I need to go here and
then I can play this position two points
down it's just a disaster and here I'm
still living for in a way but well not
nice and this helped me a bit the green
trade because I have some some chances
let's say night over here block are
blockading on the light squares and so
yeah this is just nonsense it opens up
the situation for wide
not help does not help me at all the
only issue was that he started to
blunder stuff now check is prom knee is
just um just getting too too nervous
with the time ticking down yeah that's a
really funny really funny opening line I
mean okay well to a three I cannot
really believe in it but another
possible move order to the game position
could could have been that and then a
three the question really is what into
here I mean II six that was be4 d6 yeah
well probably probably d6 I was thinking
maybe that Bishop b5 then this an option
I cannot answer with 94 this did you two
rules okay an interesting game thanks
for watching